le printemps est arrivé la saison de
tennis peut enfin commencer
bon ça c'est ce que j'aurais envie de
dire si elle avait pas déjà lu le petit
roman j'adore le tennis
j'y joue parfois jaillit pas le tennis
tout proche jamais dire que jaillit le
tennis pourquoi je déteste le tennis je
déteste pas le tennis il y en a juste
trop et vous savez que sont d'accord
avec moi
les trois coaches du tennis nadal
djokovic et federer le tournoi de miami
est le premier masters de la saison et
les trois têtes d'affiché du tennis
masculin n'y sont pas parce qu'ils ont
déjà besoin d'une pause rafael nadal
veut reposer son dos avant de gagner
roland-garros novak djokovic a besoin
d'un peu de temps en famille
il faut peut-être qui explique pourquoi
quelqu'un a tenté d'engager une modèle
pour faire dérailler son mariage
qu'est ce qu'on va faire soixante mille
dollars à une modèle pour qu elle couche
avec novak djokovic il se filme et ont
des gros budgets de production a service
eau pressurisée avec des photos sur un
style moderne et roger federer
c'est la première fois qu aucun des
trois ne sera d'un tournoi de la série
masters depuis que félix roger alias tim
a commencé à jouer au tennis plutôt que
de regarder les télétubbies y avait 4 le
tennis a le même problème que beaucoup
de sport qui savent pas se laisser
désirer
la saison est trop long le calendrier
habituel de l'atp contre 68 tournoi soit
16 de plus que le nombre de semaines
dans l'année le calendrier wta 66
le tournoi d'indian wells ce qu'on
appelle le cinquième majeur nos points
lieu cette année
et qui est ce qu'on va marquer son
absence personne vraiment personne
quelqu'un écrit en chinois soit plus
tanniques qu'est ce que je vais faire de
mon vendredi à pont peut-être antoine
des pauvres pourquoi aussi parce qu'avec
d'autres tournois de toute façon en même
temps leilani finlandaise eu le temps de
gagner son premier titre bien cadré
secoué le temps de se blesser une
première fois cette année et eugénie
bouchard a brisé sa première acquiert
tout ça pendant que leurs abords lieux
indian wells et qu'est ce que fait le
monde du tennis pendant son seul mois
pose décembre la coupe davis et les
tournois de démonstration devant des
alpes
ils veulent tellement notre attention je
peux plus intéressant avec la classe
derrière moi
c'est tout ce qu'on avait pour un
iceberg c'est tout l'espoir était comme
le tennis la coupe stanley sagan gré
pendant le camp d'entraînement du
canadien parce que la saison s'arrête
jamais et que le canadien se répand au
28 octobre à 80 de marque c'est pas
comme si la saison de la lnh était trop
courte non plus mais au moins ils
peuvent jouer au golf ou au tennis l'été
avez vous déjà vu un joueur de tennis
perfectionner son art y est l'hiver et
roger federer est probablement le seul
suisse qui ne skie pas six mois par
année
l'upi l'autre le lion 2 tonnes d'agrumes
que la seule chose qui te donne une
pause au tennis c'est perdent ou la
table de physio alors quand ils sont
tannés de jouer l'excusé facile pour se
désister nos tournois c'est dire qu'une
en polo pouces puis d'aller jouer à call
of duty toute la semaine
le remède d'olivier
c'est comme si je tendais de parents
jetaient des vies au tennis l'an dernier
le tennis a été obligé de prendre une
pause de cinq mois en raison de la
crevette 19 mai temps que 501 peu trop
400 bombes à rennes pour tous les sports
surtout ton sport favori top besoin
d'une pause des séries donc biffé mois
du calendrier les mois de décembre
janvier février et mars et les ses
soeurs des sports importants comme le
corps est cool
si vous êtes rendus jusqu'à maintenant
c'est que vous aimez vraiment pétainiste
donc partagé l'affiché
si vous pensez que la saison tennis
n'est pas assez longue vous pouvez
laisser un petit bar en poche mais
comment pourrait ne pas être assez
longue a fini jamais la saison souich
bon vrai début de saison tennis ciao
monde les fans se réjouissent moi j'ai
pas mal joué ce monument écrit vraiment
oliphant